evaluate one X when X is equal to
negative one X is equal to zero and X is
equal to one so let's do the scenario X
is equal to negative one then one X
becomes one times X which is now
negative 1 so it's 1 times 1 times
negative 1 well there's a couple of ways
to think about it 1 times anything is
going to be that anything so 1 times
negative 1 is going to be equal to is
going to be equal to negative 1 another
way you could have thought about it is
you could it'll just look at the
absolute value of both numbers you'd say
1 times 1 is 1 they have different signs
so it's going to be negative would have
gotten you the same answer either way
now we have the scenario where X is
equal to 0 so 1 times X is going to be
the same thing as 1 times 0 we've
substituted a 0 for X once again 1 times
anything is going to become that
anything so this is going to become 0
another way to think about it is 0 times
anything is going to become 0 so either
one of those ways of thinking about it
would have gotten you this answer 1
times actually we could even write 1
times X 1 times X is equal to X so
really when you evaluate any of these at
X is equal to negative 1 or X is equal
to 0 or x equals 1 it's really just
going to equal that number because 1
times anything is equal to that anything
right over there
0 just to make it clear 0 times anything
is equal to and this X here is a
variable not a multiplication sign 0
times anything is equal to 0 just for
good measure we kind of already went
over the answer but let's try X is equal
to 1 so this will give us 1 times 1
which you've probably learned a while
ago but 1 times anything is equal to
that number so it's equal to 1